hello everyone and welcome back to the
magnets Carson Invitational we are now
starting the second match after Carson
in Fallujah ended with Carson winning
two and a half one and half we are now
going to check out on Nakamura versus
Giri so this is Game 1 of their match
and already a very exciting game so I I
do hope you'll enjoy it so let's check
it out Nakamura with the white pieces
opens with d4 we have Knight to f6 by
Giri c4 g6 and Knight to f3 Bishop g7
the Kings Indian defense is on the board
with III and Giri castles here we have
Bishop to e2 and now c5 with d5 and d6
and we are now are we have now
transposed into the Ben Oni defense we
have castles by Nakamura and ecigs just
a standard idea challenging the d5 pawn
in the benoni
nice to see three and now a trade here
captures captures and Bishop to g4 as
you usually you don't know what to do
with with this light square bishop so
makes sense to develop it to g4 end and
even if fh3 give it up here for further
night so night the d2 instead by
Nakamura this night belongs on c4 where
he will put more pressure on the d6 pawn
we've got shop captures Queen captures
and now Knight to a6 and there is one
game in the database where the immediate
Knight to c4 was played but here we have
looked the d1 by Nakamura and it is as
of move 12 that we have a completely new
game so give it continues rook to e8
and Knight to c4 now we have Knight to
e4 by giri just challenging that night
offering some traits and also opening up
this bishops diagonal
Knight captures rook captures and now a
4 now that the denied has been traded
off you no longer control the be 5
square you want to play that you don't
want to allow b5 to kick away your
excellent night on c4 and this is a
beautiful night here since you're not
not only attack the d6 pawn but also
guarded the b2 points you are now free
to develop your dark square Bishop so
Knight the c7 usual idea and now Bishop
to d2 is switching the bishop over to c3
to challenge blacks dark square bishop
so Queen to d7 are developing the Queen
now preparing to bring the rook into the
game and the Queen b3 now trying to get
the rook to move you want to play some
f3 for ideas in the future and now you
either defend it with with this or you
shift it to h4 or you play f5 which is
what gierek did we have Bishop to c3 and
now rook the d8 not rook to e8 as giving
wants to be able to move the Queen so
this rocker will be guarding the pawn
and also after f3 which is what Nakamura
played you have the e8 square-free for
your other look so rook eat a e8 and now
as there's there's some pressure on the
d6 pawn nakamura decides to bring more
pressure with Bishop to e1 here he's now
shifting it over to g3 to go after the
d6 pawn so Geary says alright then I'm
going to go after your III pawn so Queen
to e7
we have Bishop to g3 and now Bishop to
f6 now planning to bring the bishop also
to help out with the attack against the
pawn and you don't ever have the
opportunity of capturing here since you
would have to give up to two pieces for
the rook which is not something you want
to do so rook ate the c1 by Nakamura and
now just b6 you cannot go
you cannot go a sex with idea of pushing
b5 it's a standard benoni idea because
white will just prevent it with a 5 and
you will never be able to play it due to
a character son b6 on Poisson so here
just b6 so maybe if the knight have
removes it maybe we'll be able to play a
six b5 with Bishop back to e 1 a Kimura
sees that he needs to bring the bishop
here to help out with the defense of the
e3 pawn so Bishop g5 puts pressure on e3
and Bishop to d2 now and the giri
returns Bishop to f6 and now a Giri
shown that this Bishop does not belong
on g3 because then Geary is free to
attack the e3 pawn so Nakamura needs to
figure out a different plan if if he
wants to push for more than a draw here
he goes for b4 he starts his expansion
on the Queen side and here was a well
this was basically a critical moment in
the game where Geary should have reacted
differently here Geary needs to go for
night that a6 put pressure on the b4
pawn and after this B 5 move which is
which is pretty much a must then go nice
to be four and here either the White
Queen moves and you win the d5 pawn or
Bishop captures and then pawn captures
and yes you've ruined up a black's pawn
structure here but blacks dark square
Bishop will now you know act unopposed
for the rest of the game which is pretty
pretty awesome as there are a lot of
dark squares for him to roam and you can
never go after this pawn
whatever you do just Bishop to c3
defends attend the deaths that's just it
so this would have been best however
give replate Queen d7 attack the a four
point and now nakamora close the
position and now this is much different
having the night here in this structure
than having the night here obviously as
the knight on c7 will not really have
anything to do now but okay Queen Quinta
f7 going after the e4 pawn and Bishop
the e1 now just defending the e4 the d5
pawn twice Queen back the e7 and now
rook the be one now nakamura is
preparing a5 he wants his b5 point to be
protected so gary strikes in the center
we have f4 but now e for a nakamura
wants to keep the center closed as he
wants to now attack on the Queen side
Bishop the d4 with check King to h1 and
now rook to b8 as a Giri of course is
expecting a five but now Bishop the c3
now threatening to pick up the bishop
and then win the pawn so Bishop captures
Queen captures and now Queen to f8 the
rooks will now shift over to the Queen
side and the Queen wall for help out
with the defending but now there's no
more time to wait it's time to strike so
a5
we have B captures an 85 by giri Queen
captures on a5 and now comes rock the b7
defending the da 7 pawn and now a
nakamura took took some time to think
about the position but in the end he
decided to go for a 5 which makes sense
you want to clear the d6 pawn to start
pushing your own pawn forward so if you
don't calculate if you don't react then
white is just free to capture on d6 so
giving captured but now d6 and Knight
the a8 now Knight the e6 is no better so
you really decided for night
yet he wants to ship the night over to
b6 and now not not well I'm not gonna
tell you what Nakamura play because
pause the video here and try to find it
the best reply for white here while I
give you a couple of seconds so for
those of you who were able to do it
congratulations on sporting the tactic
Hikaru found almost almost instantly and
for those of you who just want to enjoy
the show
it's night captures on e5 just defending
the d7 point squared twice now and now
you are ready to push d7 the problem
with capturing the night is that now d7
and there's no no way for you to prevent
this because the rope cannot go back you
can't defend it through here
and even if you go back with the rook
then the DA Square will be defended
twice by the Queen and by the rook and
if you just block it with let's say our
Queen to d8 will then just Queen
captures Queen so there's that obviously
so after Knight captures here Giri
played nice the b6 but now just d7 we
have rook to b8 blocking now as now you
can block as the night is on b6 and now
comes Rock the d2 here just calmly
preparing to bring the other look into
the game Queen a5 attacks the knight and
the pawn here but now just rook to e1
and here before deciding whether or not
the capture on d7 first King to g7 by
giri and now nakamura just played Queen
to c3 and now with all these nasty
discoveries here there's really not not
much for for black to do so with best
defense you could try something like
Queen to f6
but then this just runs into Queen
captures on c5 now and again the you
just wrap the pawn and black is still
without a move blacks only only try is
Knight captures here but then you have
Queen to c6 and again black is without a
move if you capture the Queen then just
pawn captures you will have a double
attack here on the rock and on the night
and of course if Knight captures on e5
then you just pick up the rook with
check and after whatever Queen Queen
blocks or King moves you can just trade
here character here and after an
captures rookie seven check doesn't
really matter and you will end this
position being of the exchange with a
completely winning position so this is a
this is with the absolute best defense
from black however a Giri decided that
there's no more point in playing this
game so instead he just played Queen
capture son be seven probably trying to
trying to end the game on in a humorous
tone Hikaru captured on d7 and it was in
this position that I need Geary resigned
at the game so that was Game one of
their match and we're not going to be
showing any other games since all three
were very very theoretical struggles and
all three of them ended in a draw so
basically he Karl won his match against
Geary and well just just a very nice win
for Hikaru as he did only have one point
after that loss to Magnus in Armageddon
so now that's the game I do hope you
enjoyed it a very nice attacking game by
Hikaru very nice defending him by Gary
but Hikaru did find a way he did give
him a chance with that before Gary
didn't take it and then it was just all
Hikaru from there yeah I would like to
thank Dominique Demetria Giuliana gallon
a Brian stupid that with chest look and
mister are for your contribution to my
channel thank you a lot I really
appreciate it as usual you can check to
my previous videos here thank you for
watching and I will see you soon
continuing the coverage of the Magnus
Invitational thank you all I will see
soon and have an excellent rest of your
day